[Music]
lords and ladies of the Royal this isn't
Showtime at the Apollo okay
plea make-believe on your lunch break my
daughter doesn't like real music
Patricia gets a rapper what's you guys
singing it are you like so we doing some
job so some [ __ ] I don't know why it'll
take me out of the backyard and put me
down like a dog cut the crap man I'm
gonna make this [ __ ] happen for us all
we need is a producer with the fire
beasts what's the buzz spreads we're on
the highway to greener pastures baby
[Applause]
[Music]
Gary we will be legendary I'm in my own
trap as I flip the world a birdie my
purse is full of curses cuz I'm stuck in
dirty Jersey
[Music]
who is this Dumbo [ __ ] [ __ ] never
thought once about a gym membership but
I could be someone already are you lose
your key patty keeps me the name cuz I'm
sick of that fake [ __ ] like fake tits
and facelifts the bigger the girl the
deeper the pain is the end of the
passion I hope and a prayin to sweet Dee
GG this is my life it's a remake school
mics from my queenly [ __ ] and show the
munchies big girls don't you want to
take the [ __ ] picture already
[Applause]
[Music]
you